it just seems like you have your
together do you have you ever dealt with
anxiety or depression or things like
that
ah yeah oh definitely definitely i get
and moreno will attest to it like i get
major anxiety
i i have depression runs in my family
um to a serious degree um
i and and i suffer from it at times i i
i don't
i try not to take medication i don't
find medication
like the the the antidepressant super
helpful
you know i'm i'm very wary of them but
yeah you know i think it's very
difficult
to do kind of what you're saying right
is like
the very things that make you
dynamic on screen that make you desirous
of more jobs and more experiences where
you can do
different things with with sort of your
talents
i mean this in the generic you not you
specifically
are the thing are the things that that
that also make you
anxiety written and and depressed at
times and
you know what i mean and and it's
impossible to to separate
those two things and and you question
whether you would even want to if you
could right
you could take that part out maybe you
wouldn't
maybe you'd be boring as sin on screen
maybe you would be a really bad actor
that's true what do you do because a lot
of you know my my guests
i think this show has become what it is
because i think um
it's become something else that i didn't
anticipate which was more about
you know talking to you know human
beings talking and
and seeing what makes each other tick
but also how we face adversity
what we do in certain situations and
everybody's different so
what you say you do to help maybe
control your anxiety without
as you say medication might help someone
out there who goes all right i don't
want to
take medication what does ben do maybe
i'll try that you know so what is it you
do that maybe
keeps things in check sometimes yeah and
i should say
i have a a a a
fear of of being
i have a fear of being on medication
strong antidepressant medicine that does
not mean it doesn't work for other
people and
without revealing people who they are i
have people very close to me in my life
who are on medication and is wonderful
for them and i think quite frankly they
don't think they could
they could operate without it so i'm not
saying to people who
for whom it does that works should not
do it or or shouldn't be open to it you
know especially if they have the right
doctors who are
advising them for me it's it's it's a
lot of what you you do i mean it's it's
or what it sounds like you do is like
you know it's
getting i'm most depressed when i'm
sitting inside on my phone
or on the computer and obviously
nowadays it's pretty hard
to uh to not get that way given the news
cycle so
get out get some exercise take a walk um
talk to a friend know get out of your
own head man and just get
into two two and and i will say
it's hard with kids because kids need
constant attention and constant love and
support but it's also great because kids
snap you out of that pretty quick right
like you can't
you can't exist
selfishly with children you know and
look yourself in the mirror and think
that you're even halfway disapparent
because
you ever constantly have to like our
kids are young our kids are six and four
you have to like
feed them and you know clothe them and
like play with them and teach them
like you know there's all that stuff so
that has just been super super helpful